you know it's up guys it's Marcus
Brownlee here from mkbhd and welcome to
another hardware related video this
could more or less because they're just
tutorial or review however you want to
consider it but this is going to be the
installation of the the jello skins
laptop skin I don't know if you can see
it but this is going to be the
installation of the jello skins laptop
skin that I received a couple maybe one
and a half weeks ago so I'm going to be
installing it live for you guys showing
you my my impressions of it getting you
basically a review video so right now
I'm just going to actually uh without
scratching my laptop try to cut this
open and get inside the package so they
can actually install it on the laptop so
here we go I'm going to take the outside
layer of plastic off so I'll post this
as the a video response to the unboxing
video so you can see exactly what comes
in the package but basically
installation shouldn't be too difficult
basically you want to clean off your
laptop peel it off line it up and apply
it so first thing I'm going to do is
take this microfiber here and just wipe
down the laptop you know get the dust
and whatever happens to be on it take
that off of it so that doesn't have to
be on the laptop so I'll probably I
might cut this out but it's probably not
a big deal
for you guys I don't know what this is
sounds proud touch the back of my laptop
so yeah be right back alright I've
finished cleaning off the laptop here is
perfect clean no oils or dust or dirt or
anything like that is on the laptop now
we have the skin here and basically what
we're going to do is take the skin which
actually begins at this graphite corner
right here
and we're going to peel it off and then
line it up on the laptop and just
basically kind of wipe it all the way
across make sure there's no air bubbles
if I'm going to have it on my laptop
facing this way facing out you may or
might you might not actually know what
that image is but if you watch the
unboxing video you know what it is so
here we go it's just a it's a live
unboxing or a live application so I
can't really mess up
and go back and redo it so this is
probably a little bit easier with a
smaller something like an iPod or an
iPhone or something like that but we'll
see how this works out so I just see if
we can start from one end and move
across so obviously not the entire
laptop but here we go it's very sticky
actually if it's pretty tacky it'll hold
to the laptop pretty pretty easily and
there we go
well I wasn't lined up so it's not lined
up I can yeah I can just peel it off and
redo it if it's not lined up exactly
you can always mmm you can always re
attempt it before it's all the way on so
here we go this look that looks pretty
good
try to redo that that same thing that
was pretty good installation just not
quite lined up right there huh sorry if
I'm in the camera a little bit guys I
know my arms going to be in the way
because the cameras right there but I'm
basically going to just try to line it
up and go from one end of the laptop to
the other end and smooth it out so I
shouldn't actually be that difficult I
won't be blended up so there we go I
just got a whole go ahead and pull that
from one end to the other make sure
there's no air bubbles how are you I
don't actually have a squeegee and there
was there wasn't a squeegee that came
with the laptop it was like my sixth try
so I'm going to see if we can take some
I don't know I might need some kind of
alignment device but you know I want to
show you guys when a laptop is like
skinned and everything how it looks when
it's long so I'll be right back
hey what's up I'm back and the laptop
skin actually not too long after I ended
the recording like two or two or three
tries later I got it on perfectly
aligned all the corners are pretty much
where they should be no air bubbles or
anything on the actual skin itself it's
a nice texture actually if you like if
you're carrying a laptop it'll be easy
to slide it into a laptop bag still it
won't won't be hurt or anything but I
really like
I really like this skin number one the
image is pretty cool number two it fills
up most of the laptop mine's a little
bit o thicker I guess you could say but
this that this back part here isn't
completely covered but still it looks
pretty nice I'm going to give this
jealous skin an 8 out of 10
simply because it's just well designed
it's not poorly made or anything it
sticks to the laptop very well and it
won't be coming off anytime soon it
looks nice so if you want to go check
out these jello skins you can check out
the link in the description you can also
pick your own skin and maybe use your
own design and you know experiment with
the colors see what you like and order
your own jello skin if you want to you
have a laptop you want to put it on the
back of your laptop your monitor I don't
know what you want to do so yeah that's
basically it so our thanks for watching
this tutorial or review video whatever
you want to call it and thanks for
watching guys peace